In this video we shall review how to perform bulk actions in the site tree.
The bulk actions menu enables you to perform the following tasks across multiple sites
or folders at once.
Launching a scan of the selected sites, moving the selected sites to a different folder,
or deleting the selected sites.
The bulk actions menu is displayed when you use the checkboxes to select sites or folders
on the site's page.
First navigate to the site's page and select the relevant sites and you'll notice the bulk
actions context menu appear.
From here we can perform a scan against the selected sites, move to alternative folders,
or delete the site altogether.
Please note you will require the relevant permissions for bulk actions.
These items will be available depending on your role and group.
If you do not have permission to perform a particular action on any of the selected items, the action
is greyed out.
If you have permission to perform a particular action on some of the selected items, you can
still select that action.
The subsequent dialog displays a padlock icon next to the sites or folders that you do not
have permission to edit.
These items are skipped when the action runs.
Selecting a folder selects all the sites and sub-directories of that folder.
However, some folders may contain sites that are not visible due to your permissions, which
may prevent you from performing the action on the folder.
If this happens, you should deselect the folder and select all of the visible sites instead.
Thank you.